this [__] break down and it's freestyle
it's like a chuck ledell take down tap
out [__] i pull a mac out [__] oh you
louse down low ways to pull your map out
[__] when i back out [__] i'm on the
back block [__] i was a half not the
leprechaun by the jackpot [__] i watch
matt lock [__] up in my crack spot
[__] i spent 200k for cameras in my
trap spot [__] a real street [__]
shoot you get it back to him and [__]
that's the fleet flicker casamigos i
like that but not cheap liquor won't
catch me drinking no no tito's but i
ain't from eight to year but rolling my
amigos mama i miss my mama mary watching
old shows when harry met sally
when i went to seattle i had a whole
boat i'm from h town down there we blow
dro went to tennessee i mean i went to
tennessee because my o.g he said he
still got it for tender key yeah free bg
big meech and larry hoover tatted on my
right leg chucky and freddy krueger